[Music]
all right let's go out to Kansas City
home of Patrick momes and talk to Chris
what's up
Chris hey
Chris hey Dr John what up how we
doing hey I'm doing good thank you for
taking my call today of course man
what's
up hey so um
I'm I'm feeling guilty and scared about
sharing text messages with my brother's
ex-wife which ultimately led to a
temporary loss of custody of his
children I haven't had contact with my
brother in over a year because of his
behavior mental
state we believe he may be suffering
from addiction to some illegal
substances my family and several members
of my expended family who are involved
in the situation have been scared of
what my brother may do to us
we may be asked to testify in future
Court hearings and I'm struggling with
this because I feel this is the final
nail on the relationship between my
brother and the relationship between
myself and my
father I'm sad I feel that the best
thing for my brother's children was to
be in a safe home but my brother
hopefully gets the help he needs I feel
like I'm more in the death of my brother
and my father even though they are still
alive there's a lot of history years
that led up to this latest event just
looking for someone to help me process
this so let me let me wrap my head
around it um you discovered some things
that your brother sent you that made you
really concerned about the welfare of
your nieces and nephews and it was such
that the authorities took the kids away
from
him and because you looked out for the
welfare of those kids your dad's mad at
you
your brother w't talk to
you and your brother's kind of spiraling
out and this is probably going to end up
in
court yes yeah pretty much kind of a
summary um I haven't had contact with
him um for I haven't been in his
physical preference for two years
because I haven't felt pych around him
do you think if you if you saw him you
would try to kill you try to fight you
like what do you mean when you you're
not safe yeah ex exactly yeah has he
essentially one one Wrong conversation
or one kind a mislook from from him
trying to physically you know harm me
around my children and stuff so do you
have a no contact order with the
police yeah so I went to vile one uhhuh
um during this latest they felt like
they kind of talked me out of it because
I didn't have like text message proof
that he threaten to kill kill or harm me
okay I have text messages she sent to
her mother that said that but since
those weren't directed to me um I
couldn't file my our mother could which
he said he was going to kill your
mom he was going to kill yes uh me who
my
mother he just told your mom I'm going
to kill my
brother essentially yeah okay um
I can get into more detail
but well let me just come out say do
what go
ahead no go ahead
um well before I say anything and
where's your dad at does he expect you
to protect your brother and he's mad at
you essentially yeah
um he
he's I I don't think I know he's
concerned about my my brother 's mental
state and is drug addiction but for
whatever reason um he believes
that the children are safer with the
brother and I don't believe that in any
shape of form he's under the impression
that the
ex-wife is having issues but he only
believes that because of what that
brother told him okay so so let me tell
you this as directly as I can okay
how old are
you I'm 35
okay what you did was unequivocally
1,000% the right
thing and I hate it that this is your
brother who's
struggling and you did the right
thing and I hate it that your
father is so wrapped up in his own shame
and his own
guilt that he cares more about his
reputation and he cares more about your
son's reputation and the the lies of
somebody in the throws of mental health
challenges and addiction than he does
his
grandkids I hate that for you and I
especially hate it for those
kids but somebody had to be the adult
here the responsible mature adult who
said not on my watch and that was
you
and that was
courage because you knew what it would
cost you it would cost you possibly your
safety it would cost you relationship
with your brother with your mom with
your dad and you did that to protect
those
kids and I trust you you sound
levelheaded sounds like you know ex-wife
and ex-wife probably isn't perfect
nobody is but the kids are safer with
her than with their dad and it sounds
like the authorities thought that as
well so as far as I'm concerned it
sounds like you're a
hero you save some
kids do you believe me when I say
that I do I do um I'm just kind of
uh been listen to your show now for a
couple of years
and I this this this latest you know
event has kind of just got me SP my
spiraling myself of course you know why
because your dad chose image and being
right over protecting babies and that's
probably not the dad you thought he
was and your mom had an opportunity to
protect you from a brother who said I'm
going to kill my brother and she
didn't and I can't imag imagine my
little brother's one of the greatest
people I know greatest men I know I
can't imagine looking over my shoulder
all the time that my own flesh and blood
in a in in a season of instability and
not being well would want me
dead so yeah you're right to be
completely un
Unwound sounds terrifying to be honest
with you the whole thing yeah it's been
extremely terrifying especially for my
for my wife yeah I mean even my kids can
feel it like you say moris cotton hot
there and Y and they've shown signs of
being
scared in the latest event um I I feel
better it's been several weeks now okay
been a few weeks and I'm feeling better
I'm not I'm sleeping
again um
good not not as on edge when I'm out and
about around
town but uh there has been you know some
updates and every time there's an
update I kind of feel the tense
the the scar that the T the intensity
kind of creep back in are the updates
positive or the updates
negative uh
kind kind of more kind of just not a b
not a big change um just updates in the
court okay so here's what I want you to
do a couple of things okay every time
you get one of those calls about the
courtroom your body's put a GPS pin in
this whole situation and anytime
somebody brings it up anytime you'll
talk about it it remembers hey we might
get
killed and so it hammers just think of a
hammer on one of those things at a
circus you know when you hit it really
hard and it goes all the way up and it
try to ding the Bell you know what I'm
talking about about like just imagine
that CU that's what your body's doing
cuz this isn't like man if somebody
finds out they're going to be really mad
or somebody finds out I'm G to get fired
somebody has said I'm gonna kill
you and your mom didn't do anything
about it your dad didn't do anything
about it the police haven't done
anything about it
yet so your body's
right your body's correct and so when
you feel that when you get a call from
the court hey here's the new date hey
just got court just got bumped again
we're going to ask you to testify will
you review this file and your body goes
hits that thing again I want you to make
a fist and I want you to put it in the
middle of your chest and say thank you
for protecting me I got
it don't try to fight that stuff your
body's trying to take care of you the
more you fight it the louder it's going
to holler at you because it doesn't
think you're getting a
message true and then I think with your
kids I think it's very fair to say uncle
so and so I'll just make up a name Uncle
Billy is really
sick and when he gets sick he can be
scary and daddy's been
scared and Daddy's called the right
people and Daddy's doing the next right
thing and your dad will always protect
children even when it's
hard and so what you're doing is you're
letting your kids feel your fear and
feel that tension in your home and
letting them know that the adults in the
room are still driving the
car that's how they'll grow up to be men
of character and women of character and
men and women of resilience and bravery
and courage like their
dad and here's the hardest thing I'm
going to tell
you your mom and dad have opted out of
relationship with you and I can't think
of a I mean that's just heartbreak
I hate that for
you they should be on your side walking
arm in arm protecting these kids and
they're
not is there any chance your brother
gets the help he
needs I have
hope um I know it's not going to be a
quick
thing I I hope I wake
up two years five years are down the
road and he's
better I don't know if we'll ever have a
relationship again but if he gets if he
gets sober and he gets the help he needs
for his mental health
disorders I promise you someday he's
going to turn around and say hey you're
the one that kept my kids safe thank
you you're the one that forced me into
court mandated rehab and I finally got
the care I needed thank you for loving
me when nobody else would not even Mom
and
Dad thank you for seeing through all my
bull crap and how do I know that I've
had these conversations with people out
I care about they've circled back
around but in the meantime it is lonely
and isolating and in your case
terrifying because he says I'm going to
kill
you in your heart of hearts do you
really think that's possible that he
would do that is he a violent
guy
um or is he is he a drug addict just
running his
mouth
I before he
started going down the substance abuse
life about three years ago he would kind
of run his mouth like this and I and I
didn't it feel
we
it's now that he's definitely
unstable um I I have been feeling scared
like I've been you know sleeping with a
firearm next to my bed and things like
that um because he's just
been
extremely kind of violent the way he's
communicated with all of us and and it's
not just within us it's there was a lot
of instances in public where he scared a
lot of people okay just innocent
innocent by standards you know so okay
which kind of led to this
latest that was part of the petition to
the court that
ultimately led to the judge's decision
okay me and I will defend
my I I should have probably mentioned
this my mom is involved in this her
messages are also part of the petition
so
she's he is doing something she's pretty
distraught in this sure
sure I mean I can't imagine having to go
to war with my son to protect grandkids
I mean that just sounds so surreal right
that just sounds like not real it's very
very very real and thanks for clarifying
that for your mom I'm glad she's a
person and character too and I know it
feels like there's only so much she can
do what I'll tell you and reiterate um
and again for whatever it's worth for me
because you're the one that's got to
decide I'm not doing holidays this year
I'm staying out of this stuff um and
maybe this is the Year you and your wife
and your kids don't do holidays with
your family you do holidays with her
family y'all take yourself to a weekend
getaway somewhere and y'all go
whatever y'all just stay out of
town
um
but the whole world would look different
if more men and women had courage like
you who Star down their family systems
who star down systems they stare down
brothers and sisters mom and dads they
stared
on brothers who are sick brothers who
and sisters who are struggling with
addiction and they said you're not going
to hurt kids on my watch and it might
cost me relationship with you for the
time being it might cost cost me a loss
of sleep it might cost me a lot you're
not going to hurt kids on my watch
period I'm proud of you my brother I'm
proud of you um Court can be messy so
call me anytime man and I'd love to have
you back on the show to talk through the
process my hope is your brother gets the
help and care he needs and it might come
in the in the form of a court mandate
the court says you will not see your
kids unless you go get
well and man maybe that will be one tiny
little pinl through the fog of his life
and he can at least follow that pinlight
towards the help and healing and
sobriety and peace that he so
desperately
needs thanks for loving everybody
including your
brother